THIS IS THE FIVE.
♪♪
>> DEMOCRATS GOING ABSOLUTELY
BALLISTIC AFTER GETTING JUST A
SMALL SAMPLE OF THE BORDER
CRISIS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND BLUE STATES
RAMPING UP THEIR ATTACKS AGAINST
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS WHO HAVE
BEEN RELOCATING MIGRANTS TO
PROUD SANCTUARY ENCLAVES.
RON DeSANTIS SENDING TWO FLIGHTS
OF MIGRANTS TO OBAMA'S FAVORITE
VACATION SPOT, MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
MASSACHUSETTS DEMOCRATS ALREADY
CALLING THAT A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS, AND IT'S ONLY 50 PEOPLE.
AND TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT
DROPPING OFF BUS LOADS OF
IMMIGRANTS RIGHT AT KAMALA'S
DOORSTEP AFTER SHE DECLARED THE
BORDER'S SECURE.
THE PRESIDENT IS ACCUSING
REPUBLICANS OF USING THOSE
ASYLUM SEEKERS AS POLITICAL
PROPS, WHILE OTHERS GO EVEN
FURTHER.
>> INSTEAD OF WORKING WITH US ON
SOLUTIONS, REPUBLICANS ARE
PLAYING POLITICS WITH HUMAN
BEINGS, USING THEM AS PROPS.
>> ABBOTT AND DeSANTIS ARE DOING
TODAY IN THE LEGACY OF
SEGREGATIONISTS PLAYING POLITICS
WITH PEOPLE'S HE LIVES.
>> THESE ARE THE KIND OF TACTICS
WE SEE FROM SMUGGLERS IN PLACES
LIKE MEXICO AND GUATEMALA.
>> SOME POLITICIANS WOULD RATHER
NOT ONLY HAVE AN ISSUE BUT
EXACERBATE IT TO THE EXTENT OF
LITERALLY HUMAN TRAFFICKING, AS
YOU SAID.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE WHITE
HOUSE AND BLUE GOVERNORERS
SCRAMBLING OVER WHAT TO DO.
BIDEN IS MULLING A POTENTIAL
LEGAL RESPONSE WHILE OTHERS ARE
CALLING FOR BOULDER ACTIONS FOR
KIDNAPPING CHARGES BUT RON
DeSANTIS IS PUNCHING BACK.
>> THE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA
SENT A LETTER TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE SAYING YOU NEED TO
PROSECUTE TEXAS AND FLORIDA
GOVERNORS AND ALL I CAN SAY IS,
I THINK HIS HAIR GEL IS
INTERFERING WITH HIS BRAIN IF
YOU CANS.
>> Judge Jeanine: AND THE MEDIA
IS LOSING THEIR COOL.
>> COMING STRAIGHT OUT OF THE
AUTHORITARIAN PLAY BOOK, THIS IS
WHAT'S SO DISTURBING ABOUT
DeSANTIS IS TO USE HUMAN BEINGS,
TO WEAPONIZE HUMAN BEINGS FOR A
POLITICAL PURPOSE.
>> WE CAN WORK IT OUT BUT IF
YOU'RE GOING TO BE A BONE HEAD,
WHO WANTS TO PLAY WITH YOU.
>> EXPLOITING AND ABUSING HUMAN
BEINGS.
MEN, WOMEN, AND CHILDREN, TO
SCORE CHEAP POLITICAL POINTS ON
IMMIGRATION.
>> LEAVING SOME MIGRANTS WHO
MIGHT HAVE BEEN MISLED TO
BELIEVE THEY WERE GOING
ELSEWHERE AS REPORTED TO NPR TO
AN ISLAND THAT DOESN'T HAVE ANY
INFRASTRUCTURE DESIGNED TO HELP
THEM AT ALL.
IN A WORD INHUMANE.
>> PEOPLE THAT ARE SAYING THAT
THESE CHILDREN AND THESE
FAMILIES ARE BEING USED AS
POLITICAL PAWNS ARE EXACTLY
RIGHT.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW, I
GOT TO TELL YOU TYRUS, THE WHOLE
CONCEPT OF THE LEFT AND THE
MEDIA TALKING AND CALLING THIS,
YOU KNOW, THE LEGACY OF
SEGREGATION, THE TACTICS OF
SMUGGLING, WHEN THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN ALLOWING THESE PEOPLE
IN FOR THE LAST YEAR AND, WHAT,
TEN MONTHS, NINE MONTHS, ABOUT
TWO MILLION SO FAR, 900 FLIGHTS
INTO THE INTERIOR OF THE UNITED
STATES, WHY IS IT SEGREGATION
AND WHY IS THIS ALL ABOUT
SMUGGLING WHEN A REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR MOVES 50 PEOPLE AROUND,
BUT YOU MOVE A MILLION HERE AND
THERE AND IT'S NO PROBLEM.
>> LET'S TAKE THE MILLION OFF.
LET'S JUST GO WITH THE MOVING
PEOPLE.
WE DIDN'T START THAT PARTY.
IT WAS BEING DONE BY PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S ADMINISTRATION.
THEY WERE HAVING -- EXCEPT THEY
DID IT AT NIGHT, THEY DID THEIR
LITTLE MIDNIGHT FLIGHTS.
THEY WERE GETTING RED EYES, WE
CAN'T, TO GO FROM THE BORDER TO
NORTH CAROLINA TO ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
THOSE WERE DEMOCRATS FLYING
THOSE PLANES -- THAT WAS THEIR
IDEA.
ON MUCH BIGGER NUMBERS.
AND THEY WERE TRYING TO HIDE IT
FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SO THAT IS FINE.
BUT SENDING PEOPLE TO SANCTUARY
CITIES -- NOW, I'M NOT A ROCKET
SURGEON BUT I DID ATTEND A
JUNIOR COLLEGE.
SANCTUARY MEANS SAFE PLACE,
RIGHT?
THAT MEANS YOU'RE WELCOME,
EVERYONE.
SO WOULDN'T IT MAKE SENSE IF I
WAS SEEKING ASYLUM AND I SHOW UP
AT THE BORDER AND THEY SAY WE'RE
GOING TO SEND YOU TO A SANCTUARY
CITY, THAT SOUNDS PRETTY GOOD.
SO I'M FAILING TO SEE WHERE THE
KIDNAPPING IS.
PLUS, TALKING ABOUT BEFORE, WHEN
YOU'RE KIDNAPPED USUALLY WHEN
YOU GET A PICTURE TAKEN YOU'RE
NOT LIKE THIS.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU DON'T HAVE
A NEW BACKPACK.
>> YOU DON'T HOP OUT GOING I'M
HERE.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S NOT HOW
KIDNAPPING TYPICALLY WORKS.
>> Judge Jeanine: KATIE, ASIDE
FROM THE LEGAL ISSUE, WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW TRYING TO
SELL, AND THE MAIN STREAM MEDIA,
IS THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT
VOLUNTARILY GOING THERE.
>> RIGHT.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT THE 50 OR
80 PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN MOVED
AROUND, WHO THEN ARE MOVED OUT
OF MARTHA'S VINEYARD IN A
MOMENT'S TIME TO CAPE COD, MOVED
OUT OF CHICAGO TO THE AREA
TORQUES THE COUNTY NEXT TO
CHICAGO, THAT'S OKAY.
>> IT'S JUST AMAZING.
YOU KNOW, THE WHITE HOUSE
CONTINUES TO TRY AND PIN THIS ON
THE TACTICS THAT REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS ARE USING BY TAKING
PEOPLE THE ADMINISTRATION LET
WALK RIGHT OVER THE BORDER,
PROCESS THROUGH THE FEDERAL
SYSTEM, AND THEN GETTING ON A
BUS OF THEIR CHOICE TO GO
WHEREVER THEY WANT.
THIS TIME THEY SENT THEM TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
THESE ARE TACTICS THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN USING
FOR A YEAR AND A HALF.
AND NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS BRING THIS
OUT INTO THE DAYTIME, INTO THE
DAYLIGHT, TO DEMOCRATIC
SANCTUARY CITIES WHERE THEY HAVE
SIGNS IN THEIR YARD THAT SAYS
HATE HAS NO HOME HERE, EVERYBODY
IS WELCOME, AND NO HUMAN IS
ILLEGAL, AND LESS THAN 48 HOURS
AFTER 50 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS LAND
ON MARTHA'S VINEYARD, THEY ARE
DEPORTED TO A MILITARY
INSTALLATION BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE?
NOW, THAT IS TRUE, THEY DON'T
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT WHEN YOU LISTEN TO THESE
MEDIA TYPES, THESE ANCHORS,
THESE ANALYSTS, DEMOCRATS, THE
WHITE HOUSE TALK ABOUT HOW THEY
WERE SHIPPED OFF TO AN ISLAND
THAT DIDN'T HAVE ANYTHING FOR
THEM, MEANING HEALTHCARE,
RESOURCES, INFRASTRUCTURE.
WELL, ARE THEY ENTITLED TO THAT?
ARE THEY ENTITLED TO COME TO A
PLACE WHERE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE SUPPOSED TO JUST HAVE THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE AVAILABLE TO THEM
WHEREVER THEY MAY WANT TO GO?
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
ALLOWED TWO MILLION PEOPLE TO
COME INTO THE COUNTRY, GO TO
TOWNS THAT ARE NOT NECESSARILY
DEMOCRATIC SANCTUARY CITIES,
THAN BURDEN HAS BEEN PLACED ON
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND SOMEONE'S PAYING FOR IT.
SO THE REALITY OF RESOURCES
VERSUS THE MORAL TRAINING WE'VE
SEEN FROM THE LEFT ON THIS ISSUE
IS SMACKING THEM RIGHT IN THE
FACE AND IT'S LOOKING PRETTY
ELITIST CONSIDERING WHEN IT
HAPPENED AT MARTHA'S VINEYARD
THEY'RE NOW CONCERNED ABOUT THE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING INVOLVED WHEN
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN CONCERNED
ABOUT THE TRILLION DOLLARS
INDUSTRY THEY'VE ENABLED FROM
SOUTH AMERICA THROUGH MEXICO
WITH THE CARTELS MAKING BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ON HUMAN COMMODITIES
FOR A YEAR AND A HALF.
>> Judge Jeanine: JOEY, CHICAGO
MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT BLASTD THE
MIGRANT BUSS THAT GOVERNOR
ABBOTT SENT FROM TEXAS AND THE
MOVE AS A RACIST MOVE.
AND THEN SHE IMMEDIATELY MOVED
THESE PEOPLE OUT OF CHICAGO.
THERE ARE THOSE WHO MIGHT SAY
THAT THE MOVE, AND THE MOVEMENT
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS OUT OF
MARTHA'S VINEYARD IS A RACIST
MOVE.
IS IT?
>> THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING.
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS THESE
PEOPLE BELONG IN ARIZONA AND
TEXAS BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE A
MAJORITY OF SPANISH SPEAKING
SOUTH AMERICAN OR CENTRAL
AMERICAN MIGRANTS ALREADY ARE.
SO THEY'RE TAKING EXCEPTION WITH
THE IDEA OF SPREAD-LOADING THAT
BURDEN AND IT IS AN ABSOLUTE
BURDEN ON THIS COUNTRY, OF
IMMIGRANTS THAT ARE MOSTLY
ILLEGAL, SOME ARE ASYLUM
SEEKERS, SPREAD LOADING THAT TO
OTHER STATES AND OTHER PLACES
LIKE MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
NOW, LISTEN, I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING FOR OR AGAINST MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
BUT I WANT TO SCHOOL AT
GEORGETOWN RIGHT OUTSIDE DC AND
RIGHT INSIDE DC AND YOU KNOW
WHAT THOSE REALLY AFFLUENT WHITE
LIBERALS DO?
THEY MAKE SURE THAT PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION NEVER COMES
THERE.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT THE RIFF
RA THAT COMES WITH IT.
NOW THEY'LL STAND LITERALLY ON A
HILL AND, YOU KNOW, PONTIFICATE
AND ADVOCATE FOR THOSE THAT ARE
LESS FORTUNATE BUT DON'T YOU
DARE BRING THAT TO GEORGETOWN.
I EXPERIENCED THIS MYSELF.
I GOT TOLD GO BACK TO THE
COUNTRY WHERE YOU BELONG BECAUSE
I HAD THE AUDACITY TO DRIVE A
TRUCK IN GEORGETOWN.
I KNOW WHO THESE PEOPLE ARE AND
I ALSO KNOW WHAT THE TOWNS DEAL
WITH.
YOU GO TO DALTON GEORGIA ON
UNDERWOOD RIGHT GO TO THE RIGHT
AFTER A SWEEPING LEFT TURN, A
TRAILER PARK'S THERE THAT THE
COPS DON'T GO TO BECAUSE NO ONE
THERE SPEAKS ENGLISH.
IT IS A CITY OF ITS OWN BECAUSE
IT IS OVERRAN AND STACKED ON TOP
OF EACH OTHER.
THAT'S WHERE PEOPLE HAVE MOVED
TO THAT HAVE COME HERE
ILLEGALLY.
THERE'S COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
NEIGHBORHOODS LIKE THAT ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY.
IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
RACISM, IF YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT RACISM, DON'T TELL PEOPLE
THEY BELONG IN TEXAS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE OTHER BROWN PEOPLE
ARE.
THAT'S WHAT'S RACIST.
LOOK EITHER THIS COUNTRY'S GOING
TO FIX THIS IMMIGRATION SYSTEM
OR BEING WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
I THINK WE SHOULD FIX IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: GERALDO, THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE THE HOUSE, THEY
HAVE THE SENATE, THEY HAVE THE
OVAL.
WE'VE GOT THE HIGHEST
IMMIGRATION WE HAVE SEEN IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
DONALD TRUMP BROUGHT ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS TO A 40-YEAR LOW.
SO NOW WE'VE GOT PEOPLE DYING TO
GET HERE, 800 BODIES APPARENTLY
IN THE LAST YEAR.
ISN'T IT INCUMBENT UPON THIS
PRESIDENT TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE PEOPLE DON'T DIE
COMING HERE TO DO SOMETHING?
>> FIRST OF ALL, JUDGE, I HAVE
TO SAY, AND I SAY THIS WITH THE
DEEPEST RESPECT OF THE PEOPLE ON
THIS PANEL, I LOVE EVERY ONE OF
YOU, BUT THIS WAS A WICKED
CLEVER SHAMELESS, SLEAZILY
EXPLOITATION.
>> OPENING THE BORDER?
ABSOLUTELY.
>> BRINGING THESE PEOPLE.
WHY DIDN'T, IF DeSANTIS REALLY
CARED ABOUT THEM, HE COULD HAVE
FLOWN THEM TOP JOINT BASE CAPE
COD WHERE THEY ENDED UP ANYWAY
RATHER THAN USING THESE HUMAN
BEINGS AS A PROP TO DEFAME
MARTHA'S VINEYARD OR TO EXPOSE
MARTHA'S VINEYARD'S, YOU KNOW,
ELITISM.
IT GAVE SATISFACTION TO PEOPLE
AT THE EXPENSE OF THOSE WHO WERE
TRANSPORTED.
I REALLY THINK -- IT WAS WICKED
CLEVER, NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
WE'RE ALL TALKING ABOUT IT.
THE WHOLE WORLD IS TALKING ABOUT
IT, JUDGE.
BUT THIS WAS, THIS WAS LOW.
I MEAN, CHARLIE BAKER, THE
GOVERNOR OF MASSACHUSETTS, IS A
REPUBLICAN.
AND, YOU KNOW, THIS IS -- IF WE
DON'T SEE WHAT DeSANTIS IS DOING
HERE, PLAYING WITH OUR EMOTIONS,
THEN WE ARE NAIVE.
>> AT WHAT POINT DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION ACTUALLY DEAL
WITH THIS OVERRUN BORDER THAT WE
HAVE.
>> THAT'S AN EXCELLENT QUESTION.
>> Judge Jeanine: AND IF THESE
PEOPLE ARE NOT WILLING TO DEAL
WITH IT WE HAVE TO PUT IT IN
FRONT OF THEM.
>> BUT YOU DON'T DO HUMANS.
>> Judge Jeanine: HOW DO YOU DO
IT?
GO DAWK TO THEM?
THEY'RE NOT LISTENING.
THEY'RE LYING.
HER SEA SAYING THE BORDER'S OPEN
AND NOT SECURE.
>> GET A PLAN.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHY DON'T THE
DEMOCRATS RESOLVE IT?
THEY HAVE THE POWER.
>> WITH ALL RESPECT GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS AND ABBOTT ARE NOT IN
CONGRESS THEY'RE IN CHARGE HAVE
TAKING CARE OF THEIR STATE.
YOU STARTED YOUR STATEMENT IF HE
REALLY CARED ABOUT THE